okay let's
um
okay so let's start
um thank you for coming back for the
afternoon session and i know that we
have a number of people online as well
so um we are continuing our celebration
of david blackwell's legacy today
and our next speaker is william massey
thank you so much for being online here
um william is a professor of operations
research and financial engineering from
princeton university and he's an expert
on stochastic processes
whenever you're ready william you can
share your screen and we can all see you
for those in the audience in the
auditorium today if you have questions
during the talk or at the end please
raise your hand either adam or i will
pass a microphone to you so you can ask
your questions
okay
um
are we
oh just about there
okay
fortunately i try to
sticking something extra at the last
minute
but uh there's no problem but uh let me
just ungroup this
it should be
okay so this ought to be
saw it work
okay so let me get to the beginning
[Music]
and display
okay everyone see that
um yes but it's not in full screen yet
oh perfect it's on full screen okay
thank you
okay
so thank you i think and we're in for me
inviting and letting me speak here
um so i couldn't be there in person
and uh yeah because when they were
talking about uh there are a lot of
people online and then i was gonna say
yes that includes the speaker
so uh
so um
this is kind of a mixture of uh
you know personal insights um also
research
influences and then
also why not have david blackwell also
talk about some of his own work as well
okay so
it's kind of a mixture of um
events i was involved in
also it's um
as you see on the slide there is an
interview from david blackwell's to
physical science from 1986
and then there were
classroom photos taken for life magazine
in 1962.
so i'll kind of mix all these together
um and then what i found one useful
quote
okay it's david blackwell so what do you
talk about okay or you know there's so
much to cover
so
out of that
interview
um
he sort of says this
and so i feel like well who am i to
disagree okay so i'll just um
focus on just a couple of things and not
um
try to be exhaustive
and um
oh one thing you can't tell in this
photo you notice the fellow on the right
who's smoking a cigarette
and what you can't see is that chair i
mean on the table um
they're along with the coffee cups
they're a bunch of ashtrays
yeah well this is the early 60s so i
guess a lot more smoking went on back
then
so
what's an interesting thing to talk
about
okay so it's a paper he did in
1946
and give you a time frame he uh
attended the institute for event study
from
1941 to 1942
and then after that he went to
washington dc
joined the faculty at howard university
so so this is what he was in dc area
um
so
why does he like this paper
okay and um oh and then his um notice
his um
says david blackwell howard universe
over there
um
here's some of the reason he said that
he liked this paper
okay so this is a point where he felt
like he was really getting into
statistics
okay
so um
let's do a quick sketch
of um
how did he uh what type of ideas were
you thinking about developing
proof for this
okay so
um sure everyone's familiar with the id
random variables and of course what goes
along with that strong law of large
numbers
now there's a converse that's not quite
as well known um
i have that here
you know it just says if that
limit exists then that
means the um there must be a finite
first moment
okay
so these are sort of
the tools he uses
coupled with uh you have this sequence
of id random variables
and into that you bring in the notion of
random stopping time
okay
and of course you could think of it as
okay if every
um
event is like gambling uh
when do you make a calculation to stop
okay
and it's got to be
where you are currently and if you stop
now you based it on what's going on
right now and
in the past history
so
once you have that notion of the
stopping time um
you can now state walt's theorem
and it's just so basically the iid sum
up to the random stopping time
is
you know
what should happen it's just the mean of
the you know the id random variables
times the mean of the stopping time
okay
so
um
what was the setup for the proof
um
he developed these uh
sequence of uh
random stopping times
you know it kind of informally it's sort
of like uh how long do you go
uh you know if you're gambling how long
do you gamble until you stop
decide to stop and then after
you stop to reassess where things are
maybe you'll do it again
and then
you know stop you know make the same
calculation for stopping the next time
you should go on like that
so uh because iid sequence these are all
iid
random variables two
and then
you use them to find the following set
of random sums
and you just show that those are
iid random variables as well
okay you have the setup uh what do you
do
he said well
i could rewrite
the sum of the uh sn1 to sn the k
average over k
um
i can write as a
you know the pro following products
and then thanks to a strong law of large
numbers you know that first
factor will converge to the mean of x
and the second factor you know because
their iid you know that converges to the
mean of n
but if the
you multiply two limits
and they converge then
the product converges therefore
what you start with converge now you
invoke the uh
converse to strong log large numbers
so that's how you know that that partial
sum up is still for stopping time
has a finite first moment
okay
so this is um
how he like to look at uh proving things
you know like you know
kind of deep results using
yeah well conceptually simple techniques
once it's framed to write what the right
way
okay
now
here's another thing he was
want to talk about
he was a big proponent of the
basing approach to statistics
and how come
okay
and um
i think there's one more quote here
now he's saying this
you know in the 1980s so he certainly
certainly got his wish in the 1990s
um
you know with mark you know
mark off chain money carlo methods
and um
i just gave a quick overview about what
is
bayesian statistics
following you start with information
and
you have a hypothesis
based on the information
and so the prior probability tells you
the uh
how likely is that hypothesis to be true
now
once you have a hypothesis based on the
information
you introduce
more data
and
evidence function gives you a sense of
what's the likelihood yeah
how should you know should how much to
what extension should believe this data
given their current information
and then for lack of better word i'll
just call this experiment of putting
uh the hypothesis and this uh new data
together
where you do the following
uh compute this likelihood function
so
you know basically you're saying it's
one thing to see how possible the
evidence is given the current
information
but
how does it look given uh you know your
hypothesis along with that information
and
now you um
essentially complete the square where
you have this um
develop this posterior probability
um so you're saying well you had a
hypothesis
and you looked as possibility
in light of the information well how
does it look with that information and
new data
and to be able to make
that transformation
you know that's the bayesian statistical
learning process
okay
so this is what he felt was uh him and
um
other pioneers at the time thought this
was the
good framework for looking at
statistics okay
so
let me just
briefly list you know i'm sure this is
not close to being exhausted but here's
some of the
things he had um
published papers areas of published
papers and made contributions to
from blackwell spaces to
renewal theory
markov decision theory gang theory
dominate conversion theorem for
conditional expectations
so it summarizes a lot of the things he
had
[Music]
worked on thought were interesting or
ideas he thought were important
now i'll go in a slightly different
direction
talk about a different type of legacy um
this would be uh
you know the
you know in terms of the minority
mathematicians and statisticians
um
you know the impact he's had um
directly and indirectly
so um
because i would say certainly in black
mathematics circles that uh
we would consider david blackwell one of
the greatest you know black
mathematicians of the 20th century
and um
let me first
give you this picture
uh so
this has probably taken
a
year i think it might have been like
um
2000 maybe a 2010 2009
10.
but it was the first decade of the
blackwell's hobby awards so named after
david blackwell and richard tapia
and this was conference was really
started the person who really got this
going was
carlos castillo chavez
uh this is back when he was a
professor at cornell
so i think the first one might have been
like
i guess the year 2000 okay
and so um
so i figured go with this picture it's
the first decade and um
this might have been the last photograph
we had cons yeah
um all the winners at
at a given time um that might not have
happened after this this year
and so um arleigh petters who was
at the time at duke university he wanted
2002
then rodrigo vanuelos
it was at purdue
got in 2004
and um
i got awarded it in uh 2006.
um
juaneza um
awarded
in 2008
and then trishette jackson
in 2010.
so that's the uh
folks in the first decade so um
so in some sense since we've been uh
giving this award sort of brought us
gave us the honor of being
considering ourselves a part of um
blackwell's david blackwell's legacy
and
i use as a segway to talk about
how i got in um
well sort of the mathematical influences
of david blackwell for for me
um since
one of the areas he was involved in is
renewal theory
and
if you
talk about renewals you know these are
positive random variables
you
use renewal theory to determine the
stationary excess distribution
of those iid random variables so
so lots of times we
look at systems where that that's the
service time and then the stationary
access distribution
that's important
and so we were looking at an infinite
server queue so uh oh by we is by a
colleague ward witt
recently retired from columbia
university and it was back when we were
working at bell labs and at the time we
were at lucent technologies
well i was at loosened and then ward
ended up working at 18t
that's another story
so
looking at an infinite server q with
non-homogeneous possible rivals you know
that's the lambda of t
and then uh
general service times so uh so there's
no
we only assume they're iid positive
random variables we don't put any
preconditions on the
distribution
and it turns out for an infinite server
2
um
if you start off the system starts empty
or with some poisson distribution
for all time it it has a possum
distribution
and so
you know everything just by writing down
its mean
and so the first two first equality
was writing that out
um you know you just kind of integrate
lambda from
t minus the service time to t okay
but now uh with ward
we had our
innovation that we uh
walked we
found the second inequality
would hold that you can write that
integral
express that in terms of a stationary
excess distribution
and so what do you say the mean resource
demand is going to be the mean service
rate times the service time
or excuse me mean service demand rate
times the amount of time you know so
basically how many news
resources are being requested
during the time it takes to serve one
person
so that kind of gives you the amount of
resources they're needed a given time
uh but notice
uh okay so normally people looked at
this where lambda was constant okay it
was not varying in time
but we make it non-homogeneous and you
can see there's a
not only a time dependence on lambda but
there's a lag effect
where is not just time t
minus the service time the lag is the
stationary excess so you need the
stationary excess distribution just to
express
what the time lag is
and
we looking at those issues of time lags
we put that to good use to
do a patent for
a server staffing uh algorithm um
so this is like the 1990s so our late
90s our motivation was looking at
telephone call centers
so um
but to show you how far reaching some of
these results can be so this is uh
looking at the theory of cues with
non-homogeneous plus on processes and
general service times
and um
we have this nice result you know
built on ideas from
renewal theory
that gave us a way of talking about this
okay well that's nice for our 1999. uh
what does this have to say to us
in um
you know the current day
well here was the big surprise that the
our time lag
concept
you know from the 90s
uh
we discovered the front page news of the
new york times
uh this year
okay
uh but now it's not about call centers
it's talking about
you know so the um
you know the red curve you know the
infection rates
that's kind of like the arrival rate of
patients
and then if you look at the orange curve
you know how many of them are in
hospitals that need icus
okay so that's sort of like the resource
demand okay
and um
notice how they show what they say about
the orange curve it's um it's 14 days
later
so there's so they're
really so basically
the lag effect that we saw in theory of
looking at infinite server cues
um
they're seeing this lag effect
empirically in the data of um
you know patients be admitted to a
hospital
during the covet pandemic
okay
so uh it shows you how far-reaching um
you know these ideas can be from going
from
problems with um
um you know
you know use problems in renewal theory
to
problems in telephony
to um suddenly it's useful for problems
in health care
um
in fact i say that um
if you'd asked me what cueing theory was
in the 20th century i would have said
it's
you know it's for um
you know looking at um telephone
well communications
systems and services okay
but 21st century i would say it's for
resource
sharing
services
and reason for the change is that when
you think about a communications or just
a special case
of
resource sharing
so let's move on here
uh another thing i should mention so i'm
been running these conferences called
carms conference for african bear
researchers mathematical sciences
and um
[Music]
this is when we had uh i guess we just
celebrated our
26th conference this year and this is
from the 20th uh i just want to focus on
the photo
on the uh
left
that was with um
[Music]
okay
so i blew this up because this was the
first crimes conference we had
and from your perspective it was up the
road at msri
and um
right here here's david blackwell so he
was he uh attended our first conference
so he got to meet uh so this is like the
first time we ran the conference and so
um students were so excited
to see how to see him there and you know
wasn't him talk about his work
and
also
i wanted to get back to the blackwell
tapia conference um
but this was in 2018. so we sort of
brought uh it's kind of brought
you know princeton university out in
full force to um
a mixture of um
distinguished
graduate alums you know jamal pender
who's now
a professor operations
industrial engineering department at
cornell university
and then uh robert hampshire
who is
uh well his day job is the um he's a
professor of
in the gerald ford school of public
policy at the university of michigan
uh but currently he's at the department
of transportation where he's a deputy
assistant secretary for research and
technology
and um
oh
i should mention i was talking to jabal
the other day so he was he's willing
wishing he had been there to join you at
this workshop but he is
this year he had uh son number three so
he's sort of
he's a bit busy father right now
um
oh over here ludwig tangpi who's by a
colleague in the orphee department
he works in
stochastic processes more towards uh
math finance issues
okay
and at the time these were two students
at in orphy nicholas johnson and
emmanuel
um
[Music]
emanuel so
since got his phd
nicholas was undergrad but he is now a
grad student at um in operation research
over at mit
and also before he left he became the
well not only a valedictorian at
princeton
first black valedictorian in princeton's
274 year history
oh and by the way he was the first orphy
major to be a valedictorian you know in
orphy's history so
we're very proud of him
but the key reason i bring this up
is that
one of the speakers well i spoke at the
conference but
more importantly robert robert hampshire
was also a speaker
at this blackwell topia conference
and he
works he takes cueing theory and looks
at problems in
smart cities
and so
here was a slide of the talk he gave
this was i mean that year 2018 we were
at ice arm that's where he gave the talk
okay
and
okay decision science parking management
oh and by the way um
the parking management he was looking at
it was based on data collected
in san francisco so looking at parking
issues
um over there
so what was looking at
say you just
have the data of cards just you know
going down the street and you can see if
they go by an empty parking spot or do
they choose to park there okay
and so you just say just model the
individual cars as bernoulli trials
and so you want to figure out what's the
probability the driver passed by a given
empty space
okay
so
if all the cars going by or we're newly
trials that means
the number of cars to go by until a car
decides to park will have a geometric
distribution
and
at the end of the day
you'll know how many times cars parked
there and the number of cars that went
by in between
uh that'll have
be the sum of id geometrics
and they'll be like a negative binomial
distribution
okay and so let's
summarize that
okay
okay
now you notice uh there's sort of echoes
here of you know iid sequences and then
you're looking at um various stopping
times
for those bernoulli trials
you know so you have these iid
geometrics
so
what do we do with this
um
well you um notice there's a lot of um
you know symmetry you know so a lot of
invariants under
you know a lot of events are identically
distributed you can just permute you
know they're iid
instances so you can permute them you
know so if you have a sample path looks
like this
as long as you realize the last one you
know this is uh
you know the end of the day you're
completing the data so
you know the last time someone parked
you know in a spot
um all the cars went by before that
um
it's not just knowing when this happens
it's not clear
the other other
cars if they are one that drove by or
they stopped
and parked and you can
permute um
all the dots except the last one and
then that's a
that's an event of a you know the same
probability identically distributed
so that's why we can make this statement
here that the conditional
expectation of um
you know what's the status of the jth
car
given that that sum which is telling you
all the cars that just drove by empty
spots
you know if you know that number
um
that answer is the same as you condition
on looking at the first car
that goes down the road
okay
and it's all j
um from one
you know notice that's the first one and
then you're kind of adding together
um
you know
adding together all that number plus n
minus one brings you to this position
okay
um so all of those will have the same
conditional
expectations
well once you know that
you can just add all these up
and just pull out this
factor and you know what that has to
equal if you added all all the things
inside you're adding from here all the
way to here
oops
jumped ahead okay that is the total
number of cars that went by the empty
parking spot okay
that's how you get the sum over here
okay
okay so now you can explicitly write
down this condition expectation
okay
and you got this ratio
now notice that it's strictly bigger
than
the second uh
ratio
and um
and that's going to tell you something
too okay
now you probably guessed by now uh and
so
i'm just i was just talking about cars
and collecting data and figuring out
what's the probability of somebody
passing by an empty spot
and i'm really sneaking up on the uh you
know the
rao blackwell
theorem
and here's how
so we take that top line
and saying that
this ratio
is just the conditional expectation
of that first bernoulli trial
so
instantly we can say
the expectation of this
is just p the probability that the car
passes
empty spot
now
what's surprising is that
this ratio is strictly smaller and so
the expectation of that one is smaller
and the reason that's surprising because
intuitively
you might think well
the denominator is the total number of
cars for the day
the numerator is the number of cars that
went by the empty spot
so you would think that ratio would be a
good estimation
of the
the probability that a car goes past
that of t spot okay
uh well not not quite
okay because um
[Music]
this expectation
um gives you the exact value p
okay
and so um
let's summarize those
results okay
that
what's nice about blackwell row
is that it tells you that
um
well because well let's start with the
central limit there because excuse me
strong law of large numbers
statement number one
both of these ratios are asymptotic
estimators of p okay
um but now here's where real life may
cause problems okay that if you think
about it
um
how many cars may end up parking
and a spot on a given day
you know if a car parks there for like
two hours or something
uh you might discover
you're lucky if five cars
parked there in a given day okay
um
and so um
if n is a thousand
and if n minus one is 999
you're really not going to care you know
like they're probably going to both do
good jobs of estimating what goes on
but it is only five and n is minus one
is four um now you might care you know
that might make a difference so um
[Music]
so
you're creating
uh
a better unbiased estimator what i mean
by better its variance
you know because of the conditional
expectation we know its variance is
smaller than the variance for the
bernoulli trial
and um also on top of this what we
thought was the intuitive answer
you know dividing you know using n
instead of n minus one
it's biased as a biased underestimator
okay
so
[Music]
here's a context of um
you know
robert working in uh
cueing theory is applying to um
smart cities looking at transportation
problems
and
estimating the probability of someone
parking
and looking at his estimations
it connects back to uh
the blackwell route theorem or the row
blackwell theorem or maybe i should say
rao
o paper who came out in 1945 and
blackwell's paper came out in 1947
you know it all connects
back to that so it's just
interesting to be aware of a david
blackwell and not knowing knowing he's a
black mathematician but also
realizing
if you work in the area
you can be influenced by his earlier
work as well
so um
so for a right wrap up um
let me mention uh one more important
legacy david blackwell is a phd student
now the subscript superscripts excuse me
um
for any given person those are the
number of phd students they had okay
and then oh and by the way uh
let me know if um
i may not have updated the numbers of
the phd students that the um
students have produced
and or if i left out any one of his phd
students also let me know
uh because uh the the only way i can
even think of putting this together was
making heavy use of um
you know the math genealogy database
you know because that turned out to be
invaluable
and putting this together
and so you get a sense of the number of
students he produced over over the years
he was there
from the
late 50s all the way to the
early early 80s
okay
and um
i'll just leave that up for a few more
minutes you get a sense of the um
you know what his legacy was like
oh and i happen to know that
you know for a bell labs connection ed
gilbert um
spent many uh i think after he got his
phd he then joined worked at bell labs
and he retired around um
i guess 1995.
about 40 45
40 45 years later
okay so i think that's everything
i was going to talk about
so one more nice picture
and from life magazine
and i'll end there
thank you so
[Applause]
much have time for a few questions
let's like give it a few more seconds
for people who like this if they need
more time
okay there seems to be no questions here
talk of
a lot of clarity so thank you so much
for the talk william and we hope to have
you here at some point in person but we
really appreciate you giving the talk
virtually thank you so much
thank you
yeah thank you for inviting me thanks